a lot of people have a lot to say about
your character and what has happened
this season I kind of want to break it
down with you so we're gonna start with
the season finale the ending when
there's almost a school shooting your
character shows up with the gun but clay
prevents it from happening how do you
feel about that being sick cliffhanger
and what do you think it says about your
show with everything that's happening
right now with school shootings and gun
control yeah I think that the topic is
very unfortunately it's very current and
I think that was the goal with the show
is to bring these sensitive and troubled
issues into a mainstream our show is
it's a fictional story at the cautionary
tale of clay Jensen is a character that
makes mistakes and he doesn't always do
the right thing he acts on his own sense
of justice and he acts on impulse
especially that scene at the end he's
just lucky that it happens to work out
these are not things that we're trying
to tell the audience this is what you
should do in these scenarios but at the
end of the day you know that that is the
character of play Jensen I mean
something exactly a character that makes
the smartest decision I want to talk
about another scene that's been very
controversial and that's of course the
bathroom yeah what was it like for you
as an actor to take that on did you have
any reservations and how do you feel
about there's a lot of backlash right
now do you think it's warranted as an
actor for the scene I felt a lot of
responsibility to accurately portray the
the pain and be I guess the humiliation
that one can go through when they're
assaulted in this way especially with
the stigma around sexual assault with
men and especially in this age of kind
of toxic and fragile masculinity I think
that plays a big part in in in this idea
of men being raped is that's not
something that people think about a lot
and then as a male character what does
that feel like for you in a society
where you're told that this shouldn't
happen to you
and not that it should happen to anybody
but that this can't happen to you but it
does what does that do to you on a
mental level as well as you know
physically obviously in enormous amounts
of pain and then you know I think people
are always gonna have opinions on the
show and and what we do but I think it's
staying true to what the show has been
about and you know we can't sugarcoat it
or censor it at all because that's not
how these events happen and I think it
is this trying portray and make people
understand what happens in these and
these unfortunate and tragic
circumstances where do you think Tyler
goes from here if there were to be a
season three you know I think Jessica
had a really amazing story this season
and in talking about how someone who
goes through sexual assault like that
that wrote to recovery I think it would
be great to kind of see Tyler have some
to have some recovery in there and like
see him find himself and have that that
support group around him as well I think
he has a lot of issues to work out we
see him go to a behavioral camp during
the season that specifically targets his
anger issues but that doesn't
necessarily mean that those are the only
issues that he's dealing with especially
now after is it's a salt what you do a
season three if there's a story worth
telling there absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
you